DreamWorks presents the Superman
Brainiac fight that will probably
otherwise never get on the big screen
Megamind that was my villain voice so
mega mine's the story of a villain named
here it comes
Megamind I mean all in all it's pretty
much what you can say about the movie it
is about Megamind
like think The Incredibles but for
villains and I like The Incredibles and
I like villains like a match made in
Metro City the voice actors in Megamind
are top-notch I mean they absolutely all
do their jobs to a tee Will Ferrell is
Megamind Tina Fey is Lois Lane's non
copyrighted counterpart Brad Pitt is
Metro Man which I mean that's a really
funny name because you can think of it
as Metro Man or Metro Man David Cross is
minion whose mega Minds
minion and Jonah Hill who plays the guy
that we all know at least one of who
will probably eventually shoot up your
workplace so in the beginning of the
movie mega mind battles metro man whose
voice by Brad Pitt who I mean let's face
it he's got the whole superhero vibe
voice thing going down ello citizen I'm
Metro Man stay call you shall be
protected by me Metro Man why am i
floating but then the movie takes a bit
of a turn which I really like because
it's one of those the grass is always
greener on the other side type scenarios
the kind of comic books have dealt with
a few times but you don't always see him
in movies so I really liked it no
spoilers and there is even a romance
story I mean you wouldn't expect it in a
movie about a villain but there is a
romance story and it was good it was
well done the movie made you really feel
for Megamind I mean I haven't cared
about a villain that much since the
Joker did his magic trick it is all
heart right there and I laughed at a
prospect that this movie may or may not
deal with and that is if there is one
thing that can create a villain it is
women I know sexist movie sexist the
cinematography was awesome and the
action scenes were cooler than most
things I've seen lately flying around in
a really impressively rendered 3d CGI
metropolis is awesome so despite the
fact that Megamind is about 10 minutes
too long I mean probably just 10 minutes
maybe five but 10 minutes too long today
Megamind is awesome tacular
go see it and experience further proof
that in terms of movies in 2010
September through November is more
impressive than June through August I
know except for inception in Toy Story 3
I know you were gonna comment on that
weren't you going for the comment
I got you and keep a lookout this
weekend for my collaborative video with
me and the schmoes from schmoes no calm
that is hard to say
schmooze from schmoes no calm where we
talk more about Megamind italy new
dialogue new jokes if you won't feel
like you've seen it before
I hope not anyways the point is that you
don't know my Tyrael all the time it'll
be like a whole new party but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more